[Music]
let's go to the big apple new york city
new york brian joins us there brian how
can we help
yes how you doing thank you for taking
my call sure um
yeah um should i take a consolidated
loan or a personal loan to pay off
credit card debt
in efforts to improve my credit score
and build credit history
i'll give you the short answer no
and i'll tell you why brian you know
when people go to shift their debt
around um there's one time that we
actually say that it's not necessarily a
terrible idea and it's if you have
you know a larger debt but you're able
to get a loan that's less interest rate
and you're you're in the works to pay it
off um
then sometimes we're like you know what
it makes sense and you can do that
because your behavior was already that
i'm going to be paying this debt off
but just hearing your question and the
motivation why to do that i would say no
um
because our goal
with our fun with our money at least
what we teach on this show is to be
completely debt free and not to be at
the mercy even of a credit score and so
we even teach to the point that you
become debt free and within around 12 to
18 months
after you become completely debt free
that credit score starts to actually go
down to undetermined and you end up not
really even having a credit score so
that's something that we talk about on
the show so in to in order to improve a
credit score is no is not a reason we
would do a financial move or what i
would suggest that you do so what kind
of debt is it in general is it all is it
all credit cards
yeah it's all credit card it's it's only
around 7 500. um i don't have a lot of
credit history so i thought paying back
a loan would help show some type of
credit history
yeah and it and it would but again my my
goal for you then
my goal for you is to still just pay
this off and not to work your your money
and your financial plan around the
credit score because
you can still today live life without a
credit score you can even get a mortgage
without a credit score through manual
underwriting so i don't want the credit
score to be the motivation of why you do
things because it's basically an isle of
debt score every way that your credit
score is calculated is an interaction
with debt whether it's the type of debt
you have the new types of debt you bring
on how often you pay your debt i mean
it's all calculated around debt
and
again having no debt and being
completely debt free
gives you so many other options in life
and such freedom which is which is what
we is what we talk about on the show
yeah what's your plan to pay off the 7
500 if you were not to get a loan
you got a timeline
um
i do probably in the next 12 months i
have the money to pay it off i'm paying
it off little by little i mean i just my
my long-term thing is i'm stuck at a
credit score at like 660 for a long time
and
i want to i want to raise that
i guess i'm focused on that credit score
but also i wanted i want to show that i
could pay a loan off because i do want
to get a mortgage in the next you know
24 to 36 months
so i'm just wondering how well you don't
need as rachel's address this you don't
need a credit score to get a loan for a
house
that's a that's a cultural myth
number one number two
and again rachel's made this very clear
i agree with her 100 but you realize
your credit score will go up when you
pay off the credit cards momentarily
you know because it showed that you paid
them off well it jumped for a for a
short amount of time it shows that you
paid off their credit cards how much
money do you have in savings right now
you guys are going to let uh get mad i
have enough money to pay off my
the debt um i have around nine or ninety
five hundred and uh savings um
so i know it doesn't make sense probably
i know i should just probably pay that
off but it's like that cushion to know
that i have money in savings i guess
that's what i'm holding how much money
do you make what's your salary what's
your net take home
uh eighty-five thousand okay
rachel i mean he can replenish that so
he can replenish that yeah but you can
pay off
what other debt do you have brian
i just have a car lease and um child
support that's my main two monthly
payments yeah
well i if i were in your position i
probably wouldn't be buying a home in
the next 24 months um i think it's going
to be a little bit longer for you just
from again doing it in a way that all of
this is a blessing and not a curse and
our goal is for you
to be financially free to be able to
build wealth and the fastest way to do
that from point a to point b what we
found is being completely debt free so
yeah paying this off replenishing that
emergency fund because i get it and
and
and we hear you that like it's like oh
my gosh i'm only gonna have two thousand
dollars we even it just have a thousand
dollar emergency fund and pay all your
debt off and that urgency there will
also be the motivation for you to build
up that emergency fund that much faster
so building up a three to six months
worth of expenses and then a good down
payment so again it may take i mean you
could you may be able to do that in in
two years depending on all your living
expenses being in new york you're in an
expensive place
um
but yeah being able to get out of this
car lease all of that just being
completely free from payments and i and
brian i just we just we've studied this
for over three decades and have been
focused on people building wealth
lasting wealth
and the whole idea of the credit score i
just got to tell you it is just part of
this toxic
money industry where they keep you in
this in the system
and again you're you have to con
continue to accumulate new debts to
continue to up that credit score as well
there's there's different parts of this
equation and so again playing that game
over and over and over at the far end it
doesn't get you to a point where you
really can build wealth fast in a sense
from point a to point b in the right way
um so i just wouldn't i wouldn't play
the credit score game i really wouldn't
brian if i if i woke up tomorrow and i
was you i'd pay off this credit card i
would see about the car lease which is a
whole other conversation figuring out
can you get out of it is there a buyout
where are you at in the car lease
get out of that focus yeah the child
support making sure that that's funded
and paid for and then start saving up uh
for your emergency fund and i would just
continue down the baby steps um because
again it is the plan that we have found
has created wealth for people uh and had
a level of getting out of this toxic
money culture that so many people are
stuck in and i just oh
and brian this is not at you it's not
disgusted at you i'm just the credit
card industry is just frustrating it's
frustrating keeping people in the cycle
of just
being in it and it's like and even on tv
i'm like you see all these commercials
all these celebrities and they're
promoting all cash back you know all of
this stuff and i'm like
speaking to the population that's like
okay
i'm gonna pay extra money for a
middleman to use money that i don't have
and then you get stuck in it when you
actually look at people paying living
paycheck to paycheck
and you look at the interest rate on
these credit cards
up to 25
30 can be
and then
you look at the math and it's like and
that keeps compounding and if you miss a
payment and you don't pay it off in full
that interest is added on and if you're
already living to paycheck to paycheck
you're already dug in a hole and they
just feed
the industry feeds off
of that part of population and it just
makes me mad well there's a it is a myth
and they make so much money too by the
way america they're making so much money
it's a game and they're winning but you
know a mortgage company does not care
about your credit score they care about
how much down payment you have and do
you show a financial history where
you're stable he's going to be able to
say hey i paid off 7 500
in credit card debt i've got a 20 down
payment and that's why we here's my
income here's all my other bills oh my
table myself everything that's what
they're looking at yeah they're not
looking at credit score and um you know
it's
i
i don't have a credit score
you know i don't have a credit you don't
have one either so it's like but but no
one you know that doesn't mean that you
don't have financial stability and i
think that there's this cultural myth
that you look like a flake
when in all reality if you do what you
just told him to do brian brian if you
do what rachel said you're not going to
be looked at as a flake you're going to
look at somebody who yeah i'm happy to
give you a loan and here's the insane
thing about the credit score too to your
point that people believe like okay that
means i'm good it's like this number of
i'm good quote-unquote with manchester
united
yeah and i'm like brian's great great
aunt's dog walker julia who he doesn't
even know left him in her will yes she
dies tonight he wakes up tomorrow he
gets a phone call and he's there like
you've inherited six million dollars
your credit score is still exactly the
same number brian this is true she makes
a very good you could have a net worth
of millions of dollars more and it
doesn't change your credit like it's not
an indication that you're winning with
money it's an indication that you're
hanging out with the bank and just
in debt and doing all this oh i love it
i love angry rachel folks by the way
this is this is like her actual anger
it's not even real anger it's just like
it's like a character on saturday night
live and i'm here for kids you might see
my really well that may be true but
she's right